the White House has some suggestions for
where New York City can house some of
the 60 000 Asylum Seekers that recently
arrived New Jersey the Atlantic City
International Airport is reportedly one
of 11 sites that the Biden
Administration has suggested could be
used as a potential shelter for illegal
migrants the airport is in New Jersey
and Congressman Jeff Andrew it's in his
district and he joins us now Congressman
so my understanding and first of all
welcome and and my understanding is that
this airport is in a very rural Farm
Town what do you make of that what are
what are you hearing from the
constituents that live there about their
ability to you know provide resources
for this kind of an influx
they can't provide the resources this is
a town of 50 000 people uh Atlanta
County can't do it this town can't do it
it should have never happened hopefully
it won't happen we're gonna fight this
with every ounce of strength that we
have it is the wrong thing you know when
we said what was happening at the
southern border was going to affect the
entire United States of America this is
what happens it's not just I want people
that are listening out there this is not
just an Arizona problem or a Texas
problem or a California problem this is
a United States of America problem and
now they want to come into our beautiful
County our beautiful South Jersey and
try to ruin that as well there's also a
National Defense issue here this is a
very very important issue to understand
we have the FAA Technical Center there
who's doing very important work some of
it which is very significant for the
safety of this country and Air flight
and we have our f-16s that are there as
car as of our defense as well as part of
the Air National Guard 177 Fighter Wing
they are the first line of defense for
Washington DC and New York City this is
a disaster in the making I think this is
the worst Administration I used to say
in my lifetime no this is the worst
Administration in the history of the
United States of America
you know Congress and yet you see
Congressman you see that the mayor of
New York the governor of New York their
solution is give us more money
um and we'll find more places to put you
know to put these people and they're
working with the administration to do
that it just doesn't make sense if you
have this many people that you can't
house that you don't have enough money
to do it
um and that you're willing to even put
it in places that you say could you know
compromise our national security the
answer is to go to the border and seal
it and shut it down
it's so obvious uh literally an
elementary school child could understand
so why are they doing it why are they
leaving the Border open I mean you were
a Democrat explain to those of us with
common sense how come why are they
allowing this to happen
it's purposeful it's destructive and
it's corrupt if to change the social
structure of the United States of
America it's literally self-destructive
I've never seen anything like it that's
why we need an impeachment inquiry it's
just another reason you know what I'm
doing you don't want to do the
impeachment yet at least through the
impeachment inquiry because in my
committee we would allow us to go
forward and to have more powers for
subpoena to allow us to have more powers
to investigate we need to know every
single thing that's going on this is not
a mistake it's not an accident it is
purposeful and it's harmful and it's the
wrong thing to do and he's not
fulfilling his obligations as a
president of the United States and you
know what we don't want to be a
sanctuary airport if they want to be a
sanctuary city in New York City that's
up to them it's hurting the city
tremendously too
Congressman I really appreciate your
candor
um
on all these questions thank you it's
really important God bless
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis